have asked me to go through all my  siblings names and ages so i'm going to  do that today this is my sister mary i  think she's 38 she's a property manager  and has four kids of her own next we  have greg he is 30 as a sales software  engineer then we have austin he's 26  he's a mechanical engineer then we have  me i do tic tac and youtube full-time  this is adam he's 20 and is studying  computer engineering in school brian is  23 he's still in school at the  university of arizona this is chaz he's  20 he's still in school and he wants to  be a police officer this is gabrielle  she's 18 and plays volleyball at eku  this is eva she's 16 she's still in high  school she loves horses amelia is in 8th  grade she's 14.